you've learned that the api's explorer
lets you try out the api that your
application exposes through endpoints
google uses the api's explorer in the
same way to let you investigate the api
that are publicly available for the
services that it provides for example
let's consider Google's translation
service you can go to translate
google.com to translate text from one
language to another right in the browser
hmm wonder what lemon cake is in Spanish
pastel de L'Amour I wonder if I said
that right you can use a browser like
this to do translations but you can also
write applications that do translations
using the translate API and you can try
out the Translate API using the API
Explorer it's easy to find the api's
explorer for Google's public API just
search for it here it is first result
when you go to the api's explorer you
see the list of all the api is that
google provides for developers to use
you can search or scroll down to the
translate API and click it when you see
the functions that the Translate API
exposes these are functions that you the
developer can use in your own
applications okay now it's your turn to
try out the Translate API using the
api's explorer so go to the api's
explorer for the translation service to
find out the meaning of the name gundega
in english g'day guru is our
instructional designer for this course
you can use the language translations
dot lists function to translate text set
the target language to en which stands
for english when you figured out what
gundega means in english write it in
this text field here when you submit a
translation you can tell the translation
service what the source languages or you
can let it try and figure out the source
language for itself
so one more thing for you to figure out
is what is the source language for
gundega
when you figure that out go ahead and
check the appropriate check box